the other big event that happened over
the past few days is the women's march
remember the women's march
that was an event it was just a way to
protest trump in 2016
and a bunch of women went to dc and
screamed and
the women's march always built itself as
non-partisan it's the women's march you
know it's just for women it isn't about
trump this isn't about
abortion or whatever so this year some
pro-life women decided to show up
and uh turns out that women's march is
not really about women at all it's just
a bunch of leftists there was one
pro-life woman who showed up
pregnant and said look my baby
has a heartbeat my baby is obviously a
baby
and these ghouls over here want to kill
my baby but you should see the reality
of it that
my baby's a baby don't kill the baby
and one of these ghouls uh the pro
women's march you know the kind of
radical leftists there
said that this was so offensive that uh
if she were that baby
she'd want to kill herself imagine
[Applause]
and why are you doing that to show
that my daughter is a real human
she yes she's in my body yes
i'm responsible for her but her life
matters too
and this march they're not marching for
pre-born women that's why i'm here and
my daughter's here
makes perfect sense to me and you've got
this ghoulish leftist
gal saying yeah i'd want to kill myself
if i were that baby
yeah it's awful i mean that's the kind
of women's solidarity we see you saw it
in the washington post
here's the headline women's march in dc
draws thousands in protest of supreme
court nominee
the supreme court nominee who who i will
remind you is a woman
and what a woman oh my god this one you
know truly talk about having it all
right this woman incredible judicial
career
incredible academic career and mother of
seven
five biological kids two adopted kids
now put up for the supreme court oh my
gosh the women should be thrilled right
they should be
gathering in support of this woman but
they're not because this march has
nothing to do with women it's just a
bunch of leftist ghouls
shouting disgusting things such as if i
were
a baby in that pro-life woman's womb i'd
want to kill myself
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts